اذا مشاهدينا قنبله موقوته تشكلها المباني
المخالفه في مصر فحوادث الانهيارات هذه
تحصل بين الفين والاخرى كوابيس لا يمكن
توقعها او ايقافها بسبب وجود عشرات الاف
العقارات الاله للسقوط هناك ارقام
واحصاءات حكوميه تشير الى وجود نحو 150
الف عقار هو ايه للسقوط في اي لحظه منتشره
في معظم محافظات مصر ارقام رصدت خلال
العقد الفائت وحسب احصاء صادر عن وزاره
التنميه المحليه فان اجماليه عدد المباني
المخالفه في مصر من عام 2000 وحتى 2017
فقط هو مليونان و800 الف مبنى رقم يقول
مصريون انه تجاوز ثلاثه ملايين الان كما
تشير احصاءات حكوميه اخرى الى وجود ثلاثه
ملايين
و233 الف مبنى هم بحاجه الى تدخل وترميم
بين كامل ومتوسط وجز الرئيس المصري حقيقه
عبد الفتاح السيسي كان تحدث في وقت سابق
عن مشكله المخالفات والعشوائيات قائلا ان
نصف المباني السكنيه في البلاد هي عشوائيه
وانها تحتاج الى تريليونات من الجنيهات اي
نحو 250 مليار دولار لهدمها بدورها
الحكومه المصريه ايضا كانت اعلنت انها
ستتعامل مع هذا الملف بخطه تستند على عده
مسارات ابرزها اجراء حصر لكل العقارات
المخالفه والقديمه والمتهالكه والايله
للسقوط في كل محافظه تمهيدا لاتخاذ لاجراء
المناسب
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات